okay okay okay okay
uh imagine that she's looking at the
floor okay hmm masterpiece okay acting
what is it would you know if I told you
that I wasn't lying
would I perhaps be performing the answer
only a director knows for sure
welcome to my secret to directing actors
all right
then that takes us to 129 a I said let's
get our story straight we got it it was
that kind of through your teeth one I
just [ __ ] you know I thought I saw
putting these actors come to you dead
desiccated piles of driftwood gnawed by
abusive parents and alcoholism filled
with false pride edamame
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I like all three of those
I like the first two better than the
third I thought we could recover insight
about the second was a piece of [ __ ] yep
so did I no noted is some asinine crap
noted I tell all my actors you're going
to hate me when you're finished with
this but you're going to thank me and
love me too I don't know if I can do it
uh you secretly think you might be able
to do it
I don't know if I can do it I'm a genius
director at the risk of pretense
directing is to be a god it's my job to
breathe experience into them
hello corpse welcome to life
Rick sorry sorry III can wait for this
to wrap up don't let me distract you
awake off everything is this a dream as
you spend in my life a wedding I waited
to go back to sleep
I'm in too deep
welcome to the target here of
architecture
Philby please
okay but not because you told me kill
getting darker surprise new Rick and
Morty everybody I was originally going
to do a season four video based on some
of the stuff they said during the live
episode but I'll just combine it with
this and there is a new round of that
merch giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so I always love it when
Harmon makes fun of himself I think a
lot of people were confused by some of
the promos they released like the one
where Justin roiland gets really drunk
how many shots is the right amount of
shots for drunk Rick this is my fourth
shot I'm definitely probably going to be
in the pocket after this Wow this little
baby guy I'm gonna tell you where to
stick it
good because you got it see that sounds
too sober oh it doesn't sound great I
don't believe it I know palladium 137
here a bunch of screaming demons that
just me my lips are chapped who's got
chapstick here to explain is a little
bubble Provo
[ __ ] you Christ what happens when we die
what happens when we all died you guys
worry about that [ __ ] at night alright
forget it forget me I'm drunk [ __ ] I'm
gonna need another shot to do this oh
don't take it don't say if you think you
talking about man wait like no halfway
through give me a quick wait old buddy
Lee you know I get extra booze and get
the [ __ ] out of here kid number one
thing in my three list thing is oh my
god here to explain to tell baby
princess whoa that was just for fun but
this actually was from a while ago so
even though they're animating the
episodes right now they did a lot of
that recording last year it is -
sometimes you forget that it's been
almost two years since we've had Rick
and Morty because of their normal pace
we would have been watching season three
around this time last year so that's why
they spent so much of that live episode
talking about how they rework their
process so that we'll get season for
next year and there won't be that big
production delay but I'll link the video
at the end so you can watch it but when
they were talking about season four they
were joking because Justin roiland kept
mistakenly talking about season four and
they said well you know we haven't
renegotiated yet don't tell the Adult
Swim
don't tell our agents about season four
because their contract is up for renewal
and they keep making jokes about how
crazy rich they're getting from the show
in reality they don't make a lot of
money from the show they just do it
because they love it but just because
they're still renegotiating their
contracts for season four doesn't mean
that it's not going to happen it's just
a matter of them getting a slightly
better deal than they had before
typically when you start a new series
you don't get a lot of money but if it
becomes really successful like the way
Rick and Morty has then you can get a
better deal later on I can answer that
for money it happens all the time with
big comic book movies like an actor
signed on to play comic book character
they give them a really tiny paycheck at
Marvel but then the later films they
earn way more money on so it's the same
deal if you do want to support them
though if you're buying their merch like
wearing the t-shirts and all that stuff
they do get a piece of that in justin
roiland actually in the last year or so
has started to spin off his own VR game
company called squash Tendo which is
just the best thing ever but as for
episode 2 obviously the premiere is
going to be on the 30th but I was trying
to find more information about whether
or not it was going to be episode 1
again or if they just start with episode
2 the wiki currently states that it's
supposed to be episode 2 but the wiki
also said there were going to be 14
episodes so I read it with a grain of
salt just be prepared for June 30th to
roll around and then to re-air episode 1
and then episode 2 the week after that
but what will happen now that we're
getting closer I'll be posting more and
more Rick and Morty videos Game of
Thrones and Rick and Morty are going to
rule the summer so leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below I
know a lot of you are asking what's the
deal with Rick and Beth in that Shack at
the end what's the deal with clone Morty
clone Rick so those will be some of my
next videos congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Fox mouth please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for that live episode and you
can click here to rewatch the trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]